dafür kriegst du mont und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video und
heute leute zu mir zum ersten mal auf
einem kanal lucky blogs und zwar mit dem
nun an hallo wer mir dies bei
reaktorblock 2 jacke blockiert mit am
start leuten vom normalen lac blanc und
da kommt ordentlich party jobs raus will
ich sagen leute deswegen haben wir hier
25 von den normalen sparer blogs und 121
10 7 von den babys die sie und wir
starten direkt mit diesen zwei burschen
die eigentlich durchaus nice sind wir
haben übrigens auch ohne für den nun an
aufgenommen die findet er auf seinem
kanal ist unten verlinkt mein video
component video deswegen verlinkt ich
euch mal einfach nur den kanal unten und
crew genau was machst du doch meine
treppe ich bin hier um eine treppe lol
alter als beispiel malta das ist wie
baseball mit minecraft der nice und
nochmal noch einmal und nicht in die
richtung in der andere bringt einmal
noch alter schwede jiji das war ein
homerun glaube ich und wir bauen weiter
ab 1
das heißt aus dem den tut muss ich
eigentlich gleich mal ein bisserl ist
wieder ein schlag immer nacht auf diesem
ok-power alles kann man das ja ok
das im winter blühen tiny terror-chef
gestalten warum warum sind nämlich
angelegt lasst ihn bitte ruhig wird nein
nein
die holen sich die manager cook hat man
den den dings herein in den tower ob da
noch irgendwas sinnvolles war als hätte
ich fast alles klar junge jiji
hätte ich fast übersehen soll ich werde
die sich darin okay du bist du komplett
blind aber die haben ein super lag heute
gilt diese teile haben einen lucky
wieder kälter als ich glaube schon dass
er tot ist hier sehr schön eine kleine
kitty am wegesrand
was ist das
april kegelt apfel alter spielt er hat
einfach die leute das hier
wahrscheinlich oder wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich wird es das
wahrscheinlich ist es dass bei den crimp
to crimp der kremstal wertiges und
irgendwann geboren ob ich die mit der
picke töten kann
alles ganz normal minecraft ich habe
keine chance gegen den gründer und der
lack lockern feld ohne oma opa was hast
du gemacht
was passiert was was macht man einen
kleinen dinger drin was finden sie in
der sport einfach so eine mega große
structures okay okay heute und hier
damit können wir jetzt hier unsere lucky
blogs upgraden sehr nice mit diesen
schwul oder auf einen hunderter lucky
block nicht der schlechteste dass die
allererste folge leicht die blogs
tatsächlich ein ziel alter okay ich baue
ich mein kleines häuschen nicht fragen
warum einfach ja okay also einfach alles
ganz einfach daily business so wir
spielen übrigens in einer best of three
leute hier haben wir mal ein sehr gutes
ding an lack eastwood glaubt dabei diese
anlage ist er bringt was alles klar
dankeschön dankeschön walter killerbande
okay des angeles ist zum random was sie
einfach passiert weil die kannst mir
gerne mal ins inventar droppen gebe ich
dir mal zurück oben liegt auch noch tage
auf dem grund dass sie die hole ich mir
natürlich gerne
alter schwede
das gibt perfekte die perfekt auf es
gibt effekt auf einmal hierfür und
einmal hierfür der wtf alles klar
natürlich die klassischen die arena wer
kennt sie ja dass das ist klasse trägt
und wir können diamanten gut gebrauchen
leute sage ich auch mal so sagen okay
sehr geil sergej leute seht ihr das hier
sehr geil
herr holender ein baum in gears jawohl
alter noch mal richtig viele und sieht
nicht so schlecht aus
ich muss ich muss noch ein paar chips
schicken töten
weder kann mir irgendeinen schicken
jetzt perfekt ist schon wieder so knapp
war jetzt aber auch man nur noch ins tor
also wir haben ein bisschen kies auf der
map dementsprechend hat das rechnung
nicht ganz
ich will einfach nur gucken wie es um
die landschaft hier bestellt ist und
noch mal eine single also wird man die
münze so rein und jetzt passt weiter zu
bekommen ja was man im winter gar nichts
daniel heinzmann ich hab so bock darauf
damit gar nichts zu machen halte ich hab
ja wenn du dann schild so macht einfach
gar nicht sogar
ich war halt so geil und laut ok bitte
bitte ja wohl noch drei noch 3 wir
brauchen gott jetzt bekommt er bestimmte
abend beim letzten tage über sachen raus
wir brauchen glaube ich noch ein extra
dir
nachdem ihr hit ich glaube wir brauchen
wir brauchen noch einen diamanten wir
können jetzt leider nicht auf die
fernkampf taktik gehen weil uns ein
diamant für den triples ballack lyon
profis im alter
ich geb dir einen goldenen apfel oder
eine op apfel kostet mich direkt auch
mal ein finster und dementsprechend
kümmert hier ganz flott mal einen
einzelnen fall machen denn mehr brauchen
wir nicht weil der geneigte zuschauer
gesehen haben wird dass dieses kleine
accessoire hier unendlichkeit hat ich
würde sagen dann wäre ich so weit dann
auch mal ready schick stunden später
dass das hier leute das best of three
alles klar wer zuerst zwei ins hat hat
die folge gewonnen das battle und ich
riskiere einfach gar nicht bin ready und
ich habe noch keine okay ich will mal
über die opel einsetzen
ich habe so viele effekte effekt windows
und hast du du kommst in diesem leben
nicht mehr
ich bin so happy das ist genau getroffen
super lucky op porschen vom vom lucky
villa gekauft und fucking reck alter wo
junge junge ich kenne jetzt auch so
kassel experten diesen bogen ist so
unwahrscheinlich
diese ganze gar keine chance also leute
ihr seht nur ein sieg überhaupt kein
land gegen mich fazit die runde gar
ihrer stelle mich und ich sehe ganz
schön sexy aussah das war's von dieser
folge ich habe ich gefallen aber nur
folge war das deutlich knapper als heute
deswegen bin ich auch ab wenn
herauskommt dass war es soweit von den
heutigen folgen jetzt gefährlich auf
auch jetzt aufgefallen
wenn ja dann lasst 3 weeks in den
kommentaren da wir sehen uns haut rein
macht's gut und